All right,
so Jonah gets a call from God and God
tells him that there's a city Nineveh
that's falling into moral disarray.
Now,
what does that mean?
Well,
it's a universal story.
It's like all cultures are always
falling into disarray.
It's their nature.
Just entropy does that,
right?
Things change.
The world changes.
The environment changes and the culture
doesn't keep up very well,
and then of course it has corrupt
elements and so it's an inherent eternal
story.
The individual is always placed in
relationship to a culture that somewhat
corrupt,
and then the question is,
well,
what do you do about it?
And if the answer is nothing,
well then it'll just get more corrupt
and if the answer is be corrupt too,
then it will just get more corrupt.
So the answer has to be to oppose the
corruption because that's the only way
it's going to stop.
Now,
God threatens to destroy this city
because of its corruption,
and I don't think you need to presume
anything particularly metaphysical about
that to understand it.
It's very straightforward that the more
corrupt the culture is and the less
trust is possible between individuals,
the less productive of the culture is
going to be because why do anything,
if some corrupt person is just going to
come and take it,
you know it,
it might even be that the culture is so
corrupted.
If you are good for something and you
produce resources,
you're actually more likely to get
killed because you have something of
value.
So like there's just,
you're just not going anywhere with
that.
And why would you work if you didn't
have any sense that you know,
you could store up the value of your
work for some reasonable time in the
future.
So if the society is corrupt and there's
no trust,
it's degenerating and you know,
it might live for awhile but isn't going
to last very long.
And so that's the idea.
Corrupt societies collapse.
That leaves open what corruption means.
Anyways,
Jonah,
thanks.
No,
no bloody way.
I'm not going to that city.
It can go to hell as far as I'm
concerned and that's really what he
thinks.
And why in the world should I do
anything about it anyways?
And these are good objections.
It's like,
why would you do that?
And you'll face this,
believe me in your life,
you will face this.
In fact,
you already do always constantly,
continually in small ways perhaps when
you're interacting with people who
aren't treating you properly and when
you're acting.
And those might be your parents,
they might be your friends,
they might be people at your workplace,
they might be professors,
they're playing a crooked game and you
don't like it and you know it's crooked.
And so then the question is,
well,
what should you do about it?
Well,
if you know your crib,
no,
it's crooked.
It's not so good to play along with it.
I mean,
we'll say that you know,
it's crooked by your own standard of
values.
It d degrades you to play along with it.
You're going to stand up and oppose it.
Well,
no,
probably not.
You're probably going to do what Jonah
did.
Jump on a ship and get the hell out of
there.
And you know,
that's a logical thing to do,
but it doesn't solve the problem and I
think this has something to do with
human ethical responsibility because
there are other old stories,
and I'll tell you one likely where the
son of the king,
the lion king,
the son of the king,
he goes off and he's some pathetic
adolescent and then he shamed by the
reappearance of his old girlfriend into
turning into something vaguely useful.
And he opens his eyes and he goes back
and he fights scar and no,
it's a scene of hell,
right?
Because there's fire everywhere.
And he fights.
Scar finds out,
scar killed.
His father casts him into the pit,
roughly speaking.
And then the rain comes and then you
know,
the movie returns to its beginning,
fundamentally paradise,
Paradise lost,
paradise regained.
That's the movie.
And and I mean,
that's the story of human beings.
You know,
you're in a place that's working out
pretty well.
Something happens to knock you off your
perch.
You're down in the chaos for a good
amount of time.
And maybe you never get out,
but maybe you learn something down
there,
maybe a strength in your character,
then you pop up to a new place and maybe
it's better,
better aim,
better you.
Now,
I'm not being overly optimistic about
this.
I know perfectly well that people
encounter
impediments during their life that they
find almost impossible to recover from,
but it's the best shot you have.
So anyways,
Jonah runs away,
but God isn't very happy about that
because it's actually joan as destiny.
It's necessary for Jonah to repair the
city so God sends a storm and the waves
are high and and,
and I think what that means is because
the water is often a symbol for the
unconscious and that's because things
lurk down there in the water and that
you could pull up that that are useful,
monstrous things that you can pull up
their useful.
You can fish for them.
You can go fishing in your own being for
answers,
which is what you do when you try to
think right,
you ask yourself a question and you
wait.
Maybe an answer appears.
It's like,
where did that come from?
You didn't know what the answer was
before it appeared,
what it just pop into being out of
nowhere.
Who knows?
So you fish.
So anyways,
the waves come and the boat's going to
be knocked over it.
And that's what happens.
I think when you know,
when you know you should do something.
I mean everyone has the experience,
I believe perhaps you would be willing
to put up your hands if this experience
is foreign to you.
Okay?
This part of you're telling you you
should do something and it's hard to do
it effortful and maybe you're afraid of
it and so you don't do it.
You just procrastinate.
Right?
And so how do you feel about that?
Good mean.
So what do you feel that you're
betraying yourself?
Your anxiety actually gets worse,
not better,
even though you know you can put it off
moment to moment,
but that doesn't help because every time
you put it off,
the anxiety just grows a little bit.
You're not proud of yourself.
You have a sense that you're making
things more chaotic than they should be.
You know?
And if you do that long enough,
and I'm sure many of you have had that
experience,
if you do that long enough,
if that becomes habitual,
things will get so stormy around you
that you'll fall right into the,
into the chaos,
into the watery chaos,
and maybe you'll drown.
So it's not a very good idea to run from
your destiny.
Let's say whatever that might be.
And you need a destiny.
You needed a place to aim at because
that's what gives your life meaning and
you need meaning in your life because
life is hard.
So you know,
you need something to buttress yourself
against that.
So anyways,
they wake Jonah and Jonah says hi.
It's probably my fault because like I'm
running away from something I'm supposed
to do and you know,
God isn't very happy about that.
So why don't you just throw me over
overboard.
And the crew isn't very happy about
that,
but the waves are really starting to
come up and join is pretty insistent
that he's the cause of the problem.
And so they draw,
they draw lots and,
and Jonah is chosen.
And so they decided to toss them into
the ocean and immediately everything's
calm.
So he's a center of chaos because he's
not doing what he's supposed to do.
Fine,
well then a whale comes up and swallows
them.
Then he's in the whale for three days.
Now.
That's a weird thing.
The whale,
that's the way all the was in.
That's a dragon.
It's that thing that you have to go out
there and conquer to get something of
value.
Now,
when you've made an error,
when you've
fallen off the pathway,
when you deviated from what you know you
should do,
your produces a state of internal chaos
and worry and concern.
You're.
You're thrust into the unknown.
You're thrust into unknown territory and
chaos.
You don't know what to do.
And that's often symbolized by the
encounter with a,
with a monster like a dragon or
something that lives under the water.
That's.
And I think the reason for that is,
as far as I've been able to tell,
is that human beings,
because we'd been prey animals for
forever in her battle with carnivorous
lizards,
for example,
and alligators and even dinosaurs
because there were dinosaurs around at
the time of our most distant ancestors.
And there was even a cat at one point
that was,
that was adapted with teeth to pierce
human skulls.
So it had a head that was exactly shaped
to grab you here and put a two through
the back of your skull.
So like we've come through some rough
times,
man.
And we have,
uh,
a system in our mind that's a threat
Predator detection system.
That's the thing that makes little kids
think about monsters in the dark,
right?
Because while there is monsters in the
dark,
and parents always say,
well,
there's no monsters in the dark.
It's like,
that's not true.
The darkest full of monsters.
There might not be any in your room
right at that moment,
but that doesn't mean there aren't
monsters in the dark crimes.
Take place.
Like criminals don't get up at six in
the morning and have breakfast and go
rob a bank.
They do it,
they do that sort of thing at night.
People do the things that are fit for
the night in the night and lots of
predators are nocturnal and you can't
see very well in the dark and kids
aren't stupid.
You know,
they've evolved to stay pretty damn
close to the fire because of the kids
that wandered away from the fire got
picked off by hyenas and lions and you
know,
crocodiles and whatever else the hell
was out there to eat the unwary.
So
the circuit that we use to defend
ourselves against predators as we've
evolved cortically that circuit has,
has come to represent what we don't know
in general because the predators of
course inhabit where we don't know.
And so evolution is a conservative force
and we use the circuits that we've
evolved to represent new things.
And so the unknown,
the chaos is often represented by a
monster that swallows you up and pulls
you down.
And you know when you're feeling
terrible,
you don't say,
well,
I'm feeling up.
You say,
I'm feeling down,
well,
why is that?
Well
down is worse.
I guess you're flat on the ground when
you're down or you're in a hole or
something like that.
You're hiding in a hole.
You know it's down and you're threatened
by something you know.
Maybe you're threatened by your own
inadequacy.
That might be part of it.
Maybe that's partly what you imagine as
a monstrous force because you know your
proclivity towards press procrastination
and your weakness of character is part
and parcel of why you happen to be in
the underworld and that's the
underworld,
that mythological underworld.
That's where you go when things fall
apart,
and if you understand that,
if you know that that's what that means,
then you have one of the keys that opens
up ancient stories to you and you
understand things.
Your life can be an organized,
going very well,
and then something comes up and poof.
Everything changes.
Some axiom that you were living by it,
it might be the existence of a partner,
might be a job,
but might be your health.
Any of those things go on and you go
somewhere.
When that happens,
you go somewhere,
it's a state of being.
You're still in the same world,
but it's not the same at all anymore.
Everything about it is different.
It's all negative and dark and you don't
know what to do and you're confused and
so what do you do down there in the
underworld when things have fallen
apart,
especially if if it's the worst possible
case scenario,
when you realize that you actually had
something to do with your demise,
that's really annoying.
You know when something bad happens to
you and then you know you grind yourself
into bits trying to figure out what the
hell happened and then you realize that,
well,
you were playing a causal role.
Now sometimes you're so depressed.
You assume you're playing a causal role
and your work.
It's not easy to figure out by any
stretch of the imagination and it isn't
that everyone who does something
terrible is at fault for it,
but sometimes you find that you are off
the path somehow and maybe even that you
knew it and he didn't attend to it and
that's why all of this hit the fan.
And so then down there in that chaos,
you decide that you're going to do what
you're supposed to do instead and then
maybe you get to rise up again,
renewed if you're lucky,
and then you can go fix the city.
And that's what this story's about.
And that's why I picked the image to
represent the chorus.
Because really what happens,
you see with the psychoanalysts,
the road due to health,
if you're not doing well,
which means that as you act in the
world,
you're not getting what you want.
There's something wrong with your,
the match between your presuppositions
and your actions,
habitual and the way the world is
responding to you.
And so it's not turning out for you.
And the question is,
well,
what can you do about that?
And one answer might be to examine
yourself for presuppositions and action
patterns that are not serving you well
and to find out what they are and what
to do about them.
And maybe some of that is maybe you're
not moving forward because of fear.
And maybe that's theory is grounded in
terrible experiences that you had in the
past that you've never been able to
understand and maybe one of the ways of
yourself back together and expanding
your personality so that you could in
fact live properly in the world,
is to go back to those terrible events
and untie them and straighten them out
and understand them and drop them.
And that's what psychotherapy is about.
In large part,
psychoanalytic,
behavioral doesn't matter.
What are you afraid of?
What are you avoiding?
What are you failing to develop?
Maybe from fear,
maybe from avoidance,
God only knows maybe from disgust.
How can you get over it?
How can you reclaim those parts of your
self.